[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for scott drew the head
basketball coach of the
ncaa champion baylor bears
mr big shot there scott congratulations
uh
how different do you feel if anything
you know what i woke up this morning and
first of all i slept great for the first
time in a minute i didn't need that
alarm clock i could have slept for 12 13
hours but uh i woke up and i was like
shoot what do we got to prepare for and
i was like
hey we're done it's over what did you
think when you watched gonzaga face
ucla and did that change in how you
prepared for them for the national title
game
no um we we've watched gonzaga all year
long uh we're supposed to play him on
december 5th
um i love coach few good friend um
we have two people on our staff that
were part of their staff so we have so
much respect for their guys and their
program
so uh um uh we knew what they were
capable of
and at the same time we had a lot of
confidence in our our group as well
yeah i was wondering though scott when
you're looking at them and that's an
overtime game it's emotional
i didn't know if you said to your guys
because you guys blew out houston hey
let's go adam right right away let's
let's you know
let's test them right away and see how
fatigued they might be
no that's that's a great question what i
actually thought though
is sometimes after you have an emotional
win you start off the next game and
you're really confident you're really on
fire but what happens is that game goes
on
um i think you become gassed and a lot
of times you see teams emotional win
they come out that first half the next
game and they play great
and then that's when fatigue sets in
after that now i was cheering for triple
overtime i was disappointed it was only
one so
take me back to what that 18 to 20
day stretch when coveted impacted your
team
how much was that an impact and you know
an impediment
on your team yeah well the first thing
is there is no rule book for this
everyone's going through it for the
first time so
i reached out to several coaches and got
their opinion and
um like coach izzo can't thank him
enough for his help and his
his ideas but uh most people said it's
gonna take you
uh two weeks it's gonna take you uh four
games to get back to normal
when we came back we played six games 14
days
traveled 3 500 miles so you were just
playing prepping recovering
and we never got the practice in and
then once we
lost in our big 12 tournament we were
able to practice for the first time and
dan i mean you you gotta i don't care
what sport if you go off
and all of a sudden you don't putt for
21 days and then you say go out and putt
you're not gonna be a good putter
so we actually had to practice and get
back to old habits defensively of what
we do and how we do it and then
that really was a blessing that enabled
us to go on our run in the ncaa
tournament
yeah but it's tricky because i don't
know if you thought the
season could be in jeopardy here i mean
that's it pretty severe i don't know
did you feel that way no no no no
definitely you
with with kobet there are no uh absolute
answers and i didn't know
maybe we don't come back in time and uh
maybe we can't get back to where we were
because
for most of season we were top three
offenses in the country and top three
defenses in the country
so analytically we were really sound but
when we came back our defense
every game we played dropped and we got
as low as 44th best defense in the
in the country and then all of a sudden
um after we had those couple times of
practice and really credit our guys when
we practice
they practice hard they wanted to get
better it's a player-led team
and put in time you're you know you're
just trying to get by
and our guys wanted to get better he's
uh scott drew the head coach at baylor's
been there since 2003.
you know you go back you took over a
program that
like you know i think people wonder if
they were going to get the death penalty
if that was going to happen with the
ncaa and
even when uh you know you it took a
little while to get to the tournament
you had some rough losses there i think
yale and georgia state and like if i
would have told you in 2003
scott one day we're going to talk about
you winning a national championship at
baylor and you would have said
i said yeah i i definitely see us doing
it i would have probably thought it
would have been sooner than 18 years
because when you're younger
you just assume things are easier you
know but we went to 28 in 2010
lost to the national champ and i thought
we could have won it that year we lost
it 2012 to the national champion the
elite eight
um so i mean we're knocking on the door
um
since 2008 only us in kansas and the
power five have won 18 or more games in
the last three out of five seasons we've
been ranked number one so we've been
close
and uh um uh i know when you're close
and don't get something
you're that much more appreciative when
you do achieve it i wondered at half
time though
because gonzaga cut it to ten yes and
there was momentum
on gonzaga's part and look like your
guys were arguing a little bit
and seemed like you know you looked up
and you said we're only up by ten
what did you tell your team at halftime
well we're
first and foremost we're up ten we're 20
minutes away from a national
championship
so uh um but when you're up 19 you want
to go in and a half up 19 not up 10.
but they're a great team they're going
to make a run they're going to make
coaching adjustments but i think
focusing on the big picture
and the big pictures were up 10 and
we're 20 minutes away from a national
championship
and uh davion mitchell has hired an
agent so he's going to go pro
uh we're going to talk to those guys in
the next couple days but obviously uh
davion was unbelievable in the in the
tournament and
um uh him and jared uh all
tournament teams and really uh came back
and accomplished
what they set out to accomplish yeah i
don't mean to break this to you but uh
this is what uh breaking news now just
said that uh
mitchell a potential lottery pick
declaring for the draft and plans on
hiring an agent
sources tell the athletics so yeah no no
i know i i just know like before a
formal release okay
yeah we we'd coordinate that probably
you're right everything happens on
social media nowadays yes it does yes it
does
sometimes before the coach even knows
yeah uh
your brother is the head coach at grand
canyon bryce
uh are you going to schedule grand
canyon
um it's much easier to cheer for him
than play against him so we
prefer to play in the ncaa tournament in
the final four rather than playing home
and home and homes
oh come on you got to help out bryce a
little bit come on
well if that if that's something that
that that he ever needs uh um
obviously uh it's business too so you
got to do what's best for uh uh
on the business side but uh obviously
love my brother love gcu so happy for
them
first uh ncaa appearance first
conference tournament
uh championship first conference
championship so a lot of
a lot of successful things and a lot of
great things by their program and headed
in the right direction
uh congrats scott it's been a long time
it's like uh
you know you're became an overnight
sensation after 20 years
you know well i it's it's a tribute to
all our past players that helped us get
here
administration fan support uh and god's
really blessed our program
thank you scott and uh we appreciate
your time congrats
thank you dan thanks for all you do for
sports that's scott drew uh
doesn't look like he just turned 50 but
usually coaching will make you look like
you're about 60 or something but uh
congrats to baylor